hey veritasium michael from vsauce here
and we're gonna ask some important
questions let's find some random
bystanders how about you yes I don't
believe you're scientifically literate
okay if a tomato is a fruit does that
mean ketchup is a smoothie so can you
name any of the cities in the Indus
Valley Civilisation are we talking about
like Cairo yeah got her I would not
qualify as one of the cities in the
Indus Valley Civilisation Cairo Cairo
this is Brady Haran from periodic videos
and sixty symbols
and Bible decks and deep sky videos and
numberphile and nottingham science and
food ski alright and I'm Derek from
veritasium what you want to go to one
channel ID he'll you call yourself a
youtuber by heart you want to ask me a
question triangle
um that's not a question um in what year
did the French Revolution begin 1772 you
had the first two numbers were awesome
we have a vote I seem exclusive right
now we're going to show you the first
unauthorized picture of CGP grey who's
standing here right next to me here's a
question for oh hang on he was here a
minute ago
okay so what I was thinking I might have
you try to calculate here is some
Fineman diagrams and curves space-time
but to start off with something a bit
easier I think we should start with the
Christoffel symbol for the Schwarzschild
metric um and in case you've forgotten
I've written it I've even written the
metric now I know what I know it is okay
I don't need so like oh hey no
it's in the interface triangle triangle
triangle triangle triangle triangle
triangle triangle triangle triangle
trying I am actually quite concerned
about rich guys right so this is
CGP grey and veritasium at the brain
stem conference here in canada and it's
been a great couple of days you gonna
come visit me Derek definitely I've
always wanted to visit Great Britain I
mean the United Kingdom England Great
British Isles great yes I look forward
to it
going through US Customs in like an hour
I was expecting like a triangle but this
is feeling like lots of triangles
they're happier in groups right like
they're like sheep they get sad and
lonely by themselves nice so we're in a
Corolla I don't I just do it yeah it's
like the Mennonite farms out there
wondering if this car crashes right now
like all of science on YouTube is going
down